why is my one the lunatic all right so
I've never even seen see - that's the
first time I've ever bc1 know what is
what does he say in his yeah I do you
I'm gonna read the thingy yeah yeah
section D at be 42 meters used it to
dispersed encryption matrix prisoner
sent to collect any partial decoders I
think that's 832 842 the depth says 642
on the bottom so what does that mean 624
yeah whatever
listen this is a 4 and a 6 3 the last
text in dog it says are you ok copy you
ok look up don't look up are you let's
do this I promise you guys in this one I
will not be running off on my own I
swear I just I'm not gonna be flashing
things I have no idea what's in this
level oh we're heading into doom ooh
it's red I don't like it oh holy [ __ ]
wait I've never actually seen the pods
oh there they go goodbye hi you were the
best roller coaster I ever rode just be
careful guys careful smear for luck once
you get past 50 hours you start to get a
feeling about things for 50 hours and
you only Kizer clarity's see I have
clickers - ok how many are there 3 wrong
I got glow sticks [ __ ] or now
I'm just gonna keep this door real quick
up here close it back down of course I
just wanted to peep so no one's going
down here to kill these with me
ok good you got it so we can learn
through resources right we got as many
as we need it's fine it's fine it's fine
mark it's fine what did you do it was -
I didn't see the other one that it's
fine mark
you being a stinky bum bum no guys good
news found the flashlight this guy was
about to [ __ ] me oh you don't want that
are we even looking for right now no
[ __ ]
oh it's fine it's fine it's fine it's
fine it's so fine mark it's so fine I
can you are we able to hear them through
doors I hear one yes yes oh boy all down
there with you mark yeah they are yeah
you know they are that's a lot of them
down there
they really are you got it mister fifty
hours
look man I may be a god in handsome to
match but even I have limitations in my
huge muscle ibadi glorious luscious hair
after hearing it my ears can't
comprehend what you just tried to say my
eat my ears heard it but my brain denies
it I am still human despite all my
perfections I will not Oh guys he ran
away
mark well you guys guys that but that's
problem guys this isn't the ones I heard
through the door listen Kate I missed
and it's five good guys wants a man oh
wait listen you look like you could use
some ammo I didn't oh I don't need
anything from you I don't have anything
for you there's an issue something like
thanks and I'm the only thing in my
office like a very big case to solve
in the smelly way solved all in one fell
swoop I think you're going to need to
hot dial Sherlock on that one or the
other door the one north there's no
alarm is there another door no alarm no
alarm good door do that one I choose oh
wait okay you said - security doors oh
your stinky ass misled
Humes that confused wait what does it
smell like how about we don't start
moving in right away that's cool look at
that come [ __ ] them up
you're the view kill him all right
here's one kill him [ __ ] it
are they you there's another one North
330 yeah go get a bump um
uh yeah I'm on it that's another one
north 435 oh [ __ ] yeah that's the one
it's fight gonna be getting to him again
don't make you never mind you're good he
dead he's dead don't don't do him again
hey man floor would you tell me we're
getting real cavalier with this I see
yeah funny don't worry I'm not gonna
just run in you do what you want
fires fair or whatever they say hey wait
how's it going in here
[Laughter]
[ __ ] wall just one seems alone down
there there's another one right in front
of me here up top mark there's one
there's one there's two there's one here
that I see the crazy dancer boy there's
one on this side I'm gonna do for you
guys oh [ __ ] oh that's not good please
tell me we're fine it's fine it's fine
two more two more not fine not fine
that's a lot of up oh no it's too late
no it's too late fun time I'm in trouble
I'm in trouble oh god I was in the nest
oh oh what the [ __ ]
you shot me right behind well I was
trying it that guy you backed up is that
payback
we're fine me AB object with those dudes
[ __ ] yeah thanks guys
thanks Dave we called like five of them
what do you mean things yeah why did you
get hit yeah why did you get you Berg
give me one of those med kits you better
you better give me one all right if we
are we all do we all have it out of our
systems no how have we found zero of the
thing we need to find good question
because we have a terminal oh god oh god
oh god oh god
close close where's tentacle boy right
now right by the door just at and
there's other guys around number else I
would have gone for it come in my door
my door seems like a safe passage
alright film is more anti-party I feel
like I should come over there it's more
hair than it is tentacles it's pretty
tentacle they make very tentacley noises
alright he sucked up the tentacles and
he's moving away from me
kind of toward remarks that right now
I'm going through another door scene
what the deal is over here okay okay
okay what [ __ ] guys I'm very far away
from you guys I don't I don't like being
alone you said you wouldn't go far
please please please please please
please oh yeah they're coming for me
alright help help mark go towards mark
oh Jesus Christmas I think it's this way
no re oh I am on oh my god Oh
oh we're easy I'm on the branch I could
die my name impossible mark you sound so
sad are you ok man good um you know what
I'm really good I'm doing good
oh here you are I'm fine look eat some
of this just had to take the other
horror awesome by myself
if you walk off with your own yeah
usually on the walk on my own about how
when you walked off on your own
oh yeah that's pretty much chill chill
chill
there's something here but they're not
alerted yet I have no chill and I'll see
any that's all you see him oh I see him
no no I didn't get in here everyone's
pilot whatever this is good [ __ ] okay
coming in two three on the left I think
won't follow mark he seems to know what
he's doing see that he killed that Hulse
whoa there's one there hey hello what
was that is that one behind us yeah well
we're coming
oh no oh no not again not again I'm
[Applause]
leaving
what am I on get off of the reload oh
we're good we're fine okay okay nice
start to the day you guys got it out of
your system we did that was the fact
that we're still one running around yeah
that was nobody's following Wade
specifically seems fair hey a terminal
how are we explored this much area that
we haven't found anything boy we paying
some of the decoders yeah let me look
I'm just gonna sweet weary them maybe
maybe we need to search them or
something to begin with yeah partial
decoders I don't know what you mean to
actually paying but well they're
probably listed there probably have an
official ID in the systems I've never
really used a computer so I'll leave it
to you guys in the game and in real life
P deck is what they're called there's a
total of fourteen PDX
let's go cuz we're gonna need ten well
those extras we could do extra good
stuff P deck 209 is in 94 so that's far
away I have no idea where I am oh my god
okay so you know how we're in 92 yeah
the last P deck is in 99 oh cool [ __ ]
so 93 has no P decks zone 94 has many
many P decks oh okay we need to do that
security door then probably there's also
a key in zone ninety four ninety many
PDX many supplies in 99 p decks okay we
pass through the alarm door for this
area okay Keith we're going in swinging
boys hammers out lights on Oh swung them
great oh here we go let's do this man we
turned off our lights quick to the left
four in front of me I can stick to this
one on the Left I'm gonna get some Garza
to see you in the middle yeah well
there's one more beyond it but I can get
those two I think I feel pretty
confident I'm ready to start charging
whatever you guys are hanged up you
could see where I'm standing
we're going three by mark I can't see
the third one okay let's go oh two one
got it nice okay we're gonna chill move
no no no no good okay okay
any more of about you mark for over here
one on me that wall that's glowing this
one sitting and then the one I'm in
front of in one sitting by that box
oh no I can't get through here I thought
there was a gap yeah I tried that sorry
she said I'm on my way over where's the
fourth one
there's no oh God jump over the bottom
no what are you doing
I got stuck and made some mistakes I'm
very concerned what do you mean I'm fine
now we're was so I should I need to go
east right there's more east I need to
go help kill no south against that wall
Southwest up against the wall in between
the two lit up doorways I don't see it
it's there again it's against the wall
give a direction yeah ten by me 210 is
not right there lit up right now you see
it oh yeah right okay Bob no to your
left to your left
it's it's the wall here yes yes yeah oh
that's not at the he's in the middle of
the open that's at the wall I mean it's
the wall in between the two open
doorways saw this one and was like well
that can't possibly be the one at the
wall of course it's the one at the wall
what else one is there what did we do
wrong boys wait did you swing I did not
swing now I'm in charge and then swing
once you're charged yeah I again I feel
like we had a good method before I don't
know why we changed it that we haven't
used it no I'm not assuming we're using
it I just miss it you often complains
again that's why you keep not swinging
so did you just do nothing
I waited cuz Bob was still talking so I
assume we're gonna wait for him to
finish before we just swung well there's
all three wait yeah you're right you're
right you're right you're right all
right Wade you ready I'm ready I'm gonna
charge now all right one leave those
guys over there on their own
why is it alert music it's fine we're
good we're good okay we had three there
were only two of us so we stunt killed
the last one well I took a hit
yeah he just socked him to the face and
he'll never say anything yeah no I
socked it new yes well I have a door
here going to zone 93 and 94 okay that's
good that's good
I don't think that's good contrarian I
am NOT Oh
Buki is that just a dude at the end in
the middle of the door yeah wait no
something's weird about oh it's a big
one
wait no something's off but now I hear
click ease look at the roof Oh God what
about the roof oh it's moving
oh it's robbing guys wait stop there's
something seriously wrong with these
flip things
what are you almost scared into one
there gooshie think it's Ikes what do we
do guys I got a spiky one over here come
look well I don't know if it will kill
right in front of me rules do they pulls
they're not pulsing I almost whoa
they're posting it okay there's a policy
thing kind of bigger a little no no
let's do this okay Bob let's let's both
hit it Oh at the same time got double up
on this place yeah yeah okay there's too
many to see it too oh we're gonna see
what happens I don't know why it was
tougher or looked at you yeah and charge
now oh oh you got him I didn't even hit
him you got him baby his baby is come oh
it didn't give the orange dead when I
hit it oh no is it dead it's not
interact
well it's different are you it's
definitely dead okay there's some
writing back to life okay see you can
still one shot headshot no it's gone
yeah it's gone ah so [ __ ] cool
looking
oh my god I don't like these one west of
you yeah oh one shot was a false report
I knew it yeah yeah that was the both of
us here they come oh this one started
this one that was not a one shot I'm
gonna get Jack up oh my god
thank you Wow
okay okay Wow Jill with that what's that
one over that way in Southeast huh
okay this isn't one what is this no now
we're good anyone got health no that
ceiling is very Resident Evil seven look
yeah I don't like that alarmed or
alarmed or to 95 and 96 so I assume we
have to go through it Dix needs well we
can turret this area up and try and try
and not die there's only the one way in
here right so we could just focus this
door that you know what yeah I know what
I think you have a point about the hole
in the ceiling can they they're trying
to trick us into putting it all up by
the door do this platform
yeah just cover make a line of turrets
and stay behind them on the platform
yeah
perfect everyone's in synchronicity oh
we will we will have to wait we're gonna
have to go get circles I forgot Oh balls
now we can kite for that we got it
lights on
douche bay oh boy that's a lot of that's
it just sounds like regular boy hey look
where it's going I'm just gonna head
pick that bad boy up right there Oh got
my circle done oh just one okay okay
here they come they are spikey Oh spike
Rios
Oh God yeah they're tough oh wow
what the [ __ ] hit me oh my god these
turrets do nothing I think they're
softening him up which is good okay yeah
I'm getting a lot of one pop head shots
her nose lights off nerds ooh
oh hey friend all right well good we're
back to normal
I'll take normal Oh
no more hair some squishing in the
distance spiky I hate them they're not
actually any different as far as we
could tell I just hate that they exist
see if you'd like the reinforced so it's
a little too you can't one-shot um is
that what the story is
I mind getting a one-shot but I don't
know if it's consistent all right let's
just try those two we can't you took
mark my swing didn't register so it was
definitely just you killed that one okay
wait I'm a hitman guy you follow up okay
oh my god Oh God she they do a lot of
repeated damage yeah really to me okay
he was glitched on my screen he went
through Jesus [ __ ] how much damage did
he just oh my god it was like a quick
three-pronged melee attack oh that's not
so good yeah feel so good thank God like
15 real quick looks like it's just like
a little chip thing two doors this one
goes to 94 be 95 six hundred
ninety-eight ninety-nine this one leads
to like everything we need because from
zone ninety to a hundred
oh come here below it was really opening
to spikey dudes on the left spiky dude
straight one up high oh [ __ ] there's
three here there's one right in front me
Oh friends on the platform there's three
on the stairs stairs chairs arch and
swing get them oh okay okay okay that's
good I don't know how the [ __ ] we're
gonna do this which is too
because they they hate their another
path up there I don't understand
although there is so the catwalk above
us goes to the other end if you can get
up to that platform from another angle
you come with me okay I'm ready all
right charge now yep three two one oh
dear it's okay it's all good okay yeah
they take a lot [ __ ]
so to definitely does it though yep
chimeric you guys are charging now okay
charging no I hate you nice
I got a decoder hell yeah that's where a
fifth of the way there nice don't remind
me got the regular sleeper seemed like
nothing now I know yeah you might be
able to get one on your own if you're I
think I just did get one on my own but
it also alerted everything before I was
able to kill it I don't know how much of
a second swing unique do we want to move
in on these guys over here on the stairs
yeah we're coming around now okay I'll
get in position and yeah do what and oh
[ __ ] I got clocked yeah how did I get
hit as well they suck yeah we got I
guess we do have to just coordinated
this chill oh there's three spiky
[ __ ] over here oh yeah okay here's a
weird [ __ ] maybe their weak spot is
not their head cuz it's protected by
spikes oh it's a yeah maybe I don't
think freaks when you target there but
the oh no it's just when you target any
of them I mean their chest doesn't look
very armoured I would think they're
maybe it's their gut I don't know it's
worth the test like try to hit him in
the ass Shan see what happens
okay charging charging up and swing nope
oh wait yeah
I once shot him Oh ass oh there there
chest blows out look at look at mine
down here is his chest Chris bloated yes
well I I also hit your guy as he was
coming towards me so I might have blown
him Bush on you one shot that one yeah
he didn't even like explode he just kind
of it makes sense
the head is armored that went really
well I hear a tentacle PA Oh take a
little peaky that's for sure Wyatt wait
oh my god clear shot I know I know I
know I know okay got a spiky down I'm
down there are multiple spike ease by me
I killed one [ __ ] I should've put my
turret down that's a good call use your
turrets play around each other oh [ __ ]
there's a whole crowd by me so Oh God
from your left you set up a defense as
wide as you can and make sure you know
how many attack yeah okay use your Eve
by here I just need to fight together
you're good yeah their dues from behind
okay well here's fall damage I'm out
usually when they put their tentacles
out they bend over so I was like he's
gonna bend over and then he didn't and I
was like and then I miss or I hit light
or something like that yeah we know
maybe if one of us would stop running
around everywhere yeah Wade I was ready
for it
look look it that was my fault I fully
admit it I but if you'da seen what I had
in front me it was like a clear shot at
the tentacle no one around it was like
I've done it a million times I was like
this is where I get to shine 50 hours of
this yeah someone saying the spikey boys
are weak in the back
specifically the back specifically the
hook that makes sense there's a guy
right here this is multiple Big O
there's a hole there's a giant boy right
here yeah can you watch out these oh
there's another one further down yeah
whoa we can def it's on push okay I
guess we're not I'm coming
hi are we going for this I got off I got
a front angle view all right guys I got
an ass I got the head
okay let's church [ __ ] here we go
he's not dead he's not dead he's not
dead he's not dead he's not dead he's
not bad he's dead
the other ones angry the other ones
loaded it's really okay this is great
right let's try and get him like out of
that main room before we start trying to
unload on him
oh all right that's probably good always
lick it was me what a shot sniper me
through the shelf okay well his head's
gone so you can't do that anymore oh
yeah you can they lick through the anus
or something the lick comes from within
two more big ones in there wait wait one
there's only big ones this door here the
security door is not alarmed we just go
inside of me backing up me people Jesus
this door here is not alarmed it could
just be good supplies and this one
behind us there's a lot of big uns in
there I want to go in there apparently
it's the level of the big uns this level
be thick oh no we went we went through
here before we went we went through here
before not this life yes we did
oh yeah cuz this is the bridge I had my
final glorious stand on abandon by my
friends it's not like already cleared
what surrounded by the enemies come on
over here man's a one-unit blast I'm in
the flashlight yeah that's all good man
over here with you Sean all right mark
don't miss says there's one between me
and you and then there's one to your
right there's two there's two more on
you it okay how about you come a little
slower there Bob it's only four
backwards you guys are doing great I'm
right behind ya mark how far away
okay musician could not be much further
I was judging mark hang on right there
with you
oh look we're finally in the room marks
him hey that's gone the dudes a was up
the teamwork is unknown I cleared this
whole room not this room the room I was
just in over there I know what we're
doing Bob I'm just yes ending you know I
thought the pit would develop but I
didn't really have any ideas beyond
yelling at mark yeah me after all no
okay okay what mark me you is the robot
cleared he made all dead maybe not hang
on way that didn't come back here is
bigger than five Oh dad run around as
much as you want don't go over there bit
your tongue or something leg Oh Road
bigger than I thought do we actually
have the intel on where we need to go
there's a terminal through 92 C yeah
that's where the last one I had okay we
should maybe get an idea these are I
heard the clickers
oh yeah hear that the terminal with a
manie's yes the sea anemones yes there's
a lot left three I didn't kill anything
good news zone 94 P decks great boy Oh
walk it right in there oh that guy
there's one of the right there's one of
the left guard I think I can also get
that second guy you alright
Jesus Christ
[ __ ] Marco this [ __ ] light what's
up you light someone say light we just
start swinging I don't know that's a
good idea
you can't swing without light stop
percent you moving that was running stop
running
it's it nothing's alerted okay I think
that's true it comes the music wind calm
now they're alerted probably now they
are no I was watching them be angry this
is way more fun this one's not angry she
all right it's Angry now not always you
I thought you were the one right for me
but it was green which is now whatever
bunch of babies guys you're not paying
attention to the glorious news there's
four P decks in zone 90
oh what a poor peed exit
some turrets maybe yeah it looks like
the only approach is these stairs here
I'll save mine and once we're done with
the circles I'll have it cover our
stairs okay here we go middle right I
almost laughed man whoa
take your time there white line no okay
okay we can run faster than that okay
dear but impossible a lot of homes going
back we're out Jesus where are you going
the circle isn't odd where's it going
okay
that's it I'm setting my turn up
everybody get get out the way where they
come now are they even coming hello
hello they could be through this door
these two doors over here take my turret
back yeah bad guys hello you're doing
doing not see anything oh it's not
really doing much to help but there's
one yep they're coming from over here my
friends okay send up - watch out watch
out watch out setup yeah stay out of the
door the other or get down the stairs
get down the stairs goddamn back up yeah
boy Wow
look out me so that big guy
pop and pop and pop them dead loft do it
to him that's fun
nice this is a bad room no it's Oh easy
with the sunshine I didn't hear anything
my ears wood looks like we got to refill
you want this terminal here good Thank
You spike oh yeah yeah yeah you know how
to handle a man hit him in a get him
right it is siiiick well they're all so
amorphous blobs so it's gonna hurt to
know which was the front oh I'm in the
front yeah that's the front coder Oh
chill chill out everyone relax and stop
doing that I wasn't doing nothing okay
I'm ready to kill this guy I'm looking
at his ass I'm looking at his back oh
there's a lie you got friends over there
holy [ __ ] right between two Oh coming
I'm coming Bob I'm in position just hit
this from the back right there and nail
them charging and then WHAM all right
you good yeah I'm ready okay uh Church
gonna hit him ass yep okay works a
[ __ ] treat ask does the job where'd
you hit him it I hit him high like
mid-back okay Center center shoulder
blades look ass is where it's at Madhu's
yeah why would you go for anything other
than ass why was that not your first
shot I'm gonna yeah I don't like the s
maybe that's not what I'm here for
sounds like stupid talk only one ass you
can climb it into the day and that's
your significant other no way jabbering
on about whatever woods Jeb
listen if you're gonna be an ass
Explorer be response live fast smack ass
and eat grass like an that's how it
smoke ass eat grass find a lass I
thought it was dry fast eat ass oh I
thought there's a lot more to it I guess
that's pretty simple huh Dakota oh yeah
we always six more practically Dutton
boys are you going the door we need this
is the scary door isn't it what you got
this you could do it here you do it for
me then that's exactly what I would want
you to do all right it was like don't
move let them sleep right here first
tentacley he's gone down the ramp okay
we can get these three two one wait
isn't dead sick
oh no okay okay he flopped down real
funky he did I heard a scream walk into
the room like boys and receive all right
Bob you want to get a cracker sir do you
want to know
I'm okay with like the little boys wait
you want to sit at the table you should
duck behind a box next time you got a
duck behind box yeah returns yep turrets
Bob be careful there's a dirt coming
back all right
what okay I'm watching find em watch my
head incoming behind that one [ __ ]
tentacle yeah you so close yeah yeah
need help over there mark I might be
okay the door where I'm standing
no I'm home watching our other turrets
so that we don't lose the smoke point
Jesus Christ I've missed everything yeah
I shot and I think I went through them
that's behind that's behind yeah that's
that's dead ass well I know it is I got
dude good kill yeah they're down I was
hitting it white one to the right okay
to the right oh my god to the right to
the right good kill good kill I kill you
I'm glad we all got it out of our
systems good kill guys I just see him
sprinting around like an [ __ ] he's
[ __ ] bright yes someone robbed from
me and I will not have it oh whoops
- fine Oh God oh no that's not so good
[ __ ] oh god there's so many
I set up a crossfire and then someone
else set up a different crossfire with
me those two of the door are perfect and
then this one is just everyone else
didn't get shot by it but you keep
getting do you know what that is true I
gotta give you that one that is true
look guys forgiveness for spatial
awareness guys let's just calm down and
get together going we all find the crux
of the problem with the hate we're
moving past the hate we move past it
look wait all of your past faults are
now forgive did to us wait what
hey friends yeah yeah yeah you want to
do circle stuff no just that I was like
I thought I was buried here and then one
behind me was like the saddest sincerest
oops of the day this is the spikey boy
room we did you you they big difference
i noises - I don't like it
yeah they're not as oh they're watch our
Jack looked at this way is there one
down here there is there's so much more
all I saw was his spikes is above the
edge of the thing
alright you get him I'm right in front
of him I know
take out this one here it's alone okay
it's down oh I'm gonna try this I can
help you we got these down don't we good
we good we go hit him in the hip I did
not hear him at all they're way more
quiet than the other does it matter what
part of the spine we hit have we figured
that out yet seemed like it go for the
go for middle center mass who put a
turret up I did
I mean who put a turret up what do we
what are we doing here so do we want to
just turn up these stairs is that the
call yeah that sound happened last time
they were just stairs wait wait you
badly need health I said could somebody
heal maybe never just ignore her you
need to yell odor honestly absolutely
make her heal you yeah I'll keep that up
Oh God character get in the circle
oh here I am left boy it'll ride middle
I have my left boy circle right here oh
oh yeah oh they are my god my god oh my
god there's a several of them dear sorry
but if that hit you sorry sorry sorry no
it's fine it's all I shouldn't have
walked up yeah I'm there I'm a very yeah
I think those guys are spooky if their
backs the weak point that means we're
losing a lot of ammo try to shoot him in
the face - well no other way all right
oh we can put art we could put our
shotguns facing backwards why weren't
you ready to back up I was a countdown
on that they were moving he runs so far
away removing all the tentacles all I
heard was the tentacles and I wasn't
sure how close they would be no there
they go that's why I was giving it space
person always gets licked by the
tentacle it's fine
oh that one tented alright man he's
coming in yeah I don't want your [ __ ]
ramen noodle tippy oh they cousins
oh it come and they come and long how
are we supposed to get in there at least
say mark go in there get him always
worked so far I'm still very new to the
whole man technicals are risky no matter
what I've killed a bunch I've also
trigger oh you're safe I think mark yeah
we need like hedge clippers so we can
like cook them okay come over here no
it's going down there's two big bad boys
or three around that corner yeah I see
at least two okay it's done I might be
able to get those those you might be
able to get those guys there's three if
you're quick oh oh there's a fourth
wheel chill chill chill chill
is that a big one in the corner are we
safe from the licks mark not anymore
it's coming back up go around Mark's way
what I'm gonna try to do is I'm at red
drop it's coming it's come in the wall
I'm at the wall I'm gonna let me go
through [ __ ] walls no no they uh oh
my god that's not good at all that's a
bad okay I'm down right here oh no it's
coming up this way there's I'm gonna
drop by itself here oh [ __ ] watch out
heads up stay alert
stay frosty you got this doesn't affect
nexium on the move okay all right we're
good okay it's coming down here no yes
okay maybe we just mosey past this zone
and get to the next one oh yeah see
what's through here and maybe just
please oh it's fine we need to like make
executive decisions fast you know we got
are we getting in and closing so what
we're doing I think that's the best goal
okay I'm gonna go for the switch closed
down there's one right there to the
right mark yeah farther to the right or
is this you wait wait down or up all
right right do you oh [ __ ]
yep okay you ready wait yep there's two
right I mean to me there's also a little
one oh yeah you can probably get him and
then come get down I'm down I'm down
oh [ __ ] I don't know why I didn't die I
got it in the head oh oh [ __ ] the whole
room out what sucks I'm dead oh my god
my dudes is a white burrito I don't know
why that happened my shot was right the
head I'm still like the last one up Jack
okay clear
oh wow Wow watch my bad guys I don't
know what I did wrong there I was just a
normal dude off the head it just didn't
work
stupid glancing shoulders sometimes wait
how are you doing on ammo Oh 60 375 I'm
okay
wait mark do you need more I mean a
cable some more come here no mark come
here dripping or tentacles to my right I
can't oh yeah this is the rule that's
the drippy door that one that one this
this entrance that the drips was
actually pretty good for us until that
digs happened oh yeah this is the same
oh [ __ ]
Oh big boy I'm gonna open this other
door just just just have a look see you
know don't what are you doing go on kill
him things Oh where's the next one
it's behind here
oh I got it alright I enjoy the noises
you make when you're pop you get that
one I'll get this one
okay okay I'm charged oh don't don't
I'm okay oh wow what what the [ __ ]
whoa what what yeah he's okay glitched
yeah no [ __ ] just gave him stunlock keep
him son locked down there so many I'm so
the app dead it's my time to shine my
time - oh god I forgot they have tongues
these guys - nevermind
god damn he just triggered and went
through the wall weird he like he likes
spun around and moved a bunch right
after you tried to get him yeah that'll
be it for me - yeah that's a good one to
end on
[Music]